this is a production of cornell
university
okay so before i start talking about
and the symbionts of fungi i would like
to set up a stage for this discussion
um
give you
give you
um
an idea of a conceptual framework
that we have been using and are still
using
to think about
evolution
of
endosymbiotic bacteria in fungi so
endosymbiotic bacteria
are a source of evolutionary innovation
and the most potent example
is uh the endosymbiotic origin
of the eukaryotic cell
both mitochondria and chloroplasts
originated by engulfment
of alpha proteobacteria that gave rise
to mitochondria
in a cyanobacteria that gave rise to
present-day chloroplasts
and
evolutionary biologists have spent a lot
of time thinking about
stability
of this new construct of this
evolutionary innovation in a sense that
both chloroplasts and mitochondria are
prone because of their prokaryotic
inheritance
nature
would be prone to
uh degeneration
in a collapse
of the association
with the eukaryotic cell
and so
we believe that the
evolutionary stability
of the eukaryotic cell
being able to host these two organelles
comes from the gene transfer
see that see the cartoon here from the
gene transfer from both
mitochondria and chloroplasts
to the host nucleus
now another example of
a major evolutionary innovation
are the endosymbiotic associations
of insects
uh endosymbiotic bacteria are credited
for
phylogenetic
explosion diversification of insects
because they
allow insects to explore
various niches by providing metabolic
complementation
and um i am giving you
um
three most charismatic examples
buchner affidicola that supplements
aphids
with amino acids aphids live on
sugar rich but amino acids pour phloems
up
candidates tremblaya princeps
are substitu
supplements mealybugs similarly uh with
amino acids and i am mentioning
tremblaya because tremblaya is a proteo
is a better proteobacterium closely
related to endosymbionts of fungi
in
as an example of a different flavor of
metabolic complementation
wigglesworthia
glossy media
who helps sidsi flies
by provisioning them with
b vitamins that are lacking or limited
in blood meal of the
of city flies
um
unfortunately
this innovation is unstable
the
um
there because insects
about 70 percent of insects
have uh bacterial endosymbionts and
insects are important
economic pests there has been a lot of
work done to understand their lifestyles
and the organisms that help them survive
in various niches
so there is a paradigm formulated about
the evolution of bacterial endosymbionts
based on studies of bacterial
endosymbionts of insects and i should
say that these are essential
endosymbionts meaning that removal of
the endosymbiont will
kill the host
well it turns out that
that
i'm sorry i am
my oh
weird
um i've just realized that
i am not showing my full screen that's
okay um
so
based on these
ample studies we know
that the genome evolution and
evolutionary trajectory of and the
symbionts of insects
is a degenerative one
uh and the symbionts of insects over
time
will
um extinct
in their specific hosts and unless they
are replaced by other uh symbionts
provisioning the same service
the whole association will go extinct
so there are three
uh elements of the
of this framework these endosymbionts
are heritable they are inherited from
one host generation to the next
um they
show genome contraction
these genomes are tiny low genomes
and these endosymbionts also show
acceleration of the molecular evolution
rate
uh compared to their close relatives
uh
meaning that you when you look at
phylogenetic trees and i will show you
one um shortly uh the branches on the on
which symbionts are located are much
longer than uh free-living branches so
what happens
well so
these effects genome control genome
contraction and molecular evolution rate
acceleration are related to population
genetic processes that happen in um
endosymbiotic populations those
populations are subdivided they are
clonal
and they are suffer transmission
bottlenecks this
all uh accumulates in reduction of
effective population size and as you
know small populations uh have
suffer
um magnification of genetic drift
relative to selection so selection is
unable to weed out
actual slightly deleterious mutations
that accumulate at random in the genome
so genes lose functions but they are
random genes in the genome because
bacterial evolution
prefers
uh elimination of
genes that are disabled genome contracts
so this is
this is something that
um
we
always keep in mind
when we think about endosymbionts
of fungi as a reference framework
now let's go to
bacterial and the symbionts of
fungi well fungi are increasingly
particularly in the last decade
recognized as hosts to endobacteria
and
as kilian said we are particularly
interested in early divergent fungi in
the phylum mucoromycota
and we specifically
studied two subphyla nuclear mycotina
and
glomerulomycotina
and the question that we're asking or
that we have been asking
was uh
how these endosymbiotic bacteria in
fungi achieve evolutionary stability or
how these
entire associations
can be stably maintained
um if the paradigm drawn from a
different system suggests
that these associations should go
extinct
so let's start from from
glomerulomycotina our vascular
mycorrhizal fungi i don't have to um
introduce this particular system to this
audience but nevertheless i will say amf
are
symbionts of most
uh terrestrial plants they are obligate
biotrophs they depend on on plant
assimilated carbon
uh in return for mineral nutrients
from soil
there is a potential to use them as
chemical fertilizer substitutes
mycorrhizal fungi are credited
with facilitation of emergence
of aquatic plants in the uh our
transition of earlier
aquatic plants in early devonian to the
terrestrial habitat and what i am
showing you here is a root of leek
surrounded by hyphen spores of glomus
etunicatum or chloroidograms
and this is a section of root that is
sustained
to visualize
fungal hyphae arbuscular mycorrhizal
fungi were the first fungi
that have been actually reported or
demonstrated to harbor bacterial
endosymbionts in their cells so here
again a collection of
spores these are asexual spores fairly
large
of amf
and this is a
electron micrograph
showing
accumulation of bacterial cells in the
cytoplasm of an arbuscular mycorrhizal
fungus and this study was conducted by
barbara mossy the founding mother
of the mycorrhizal research field
and
and that's how the story started
so
uh at in the 70s obviously nobody knew
what these bacterial bacterial
endosymbionts were
we became interested in those bacterial
endosymbionts and we started working on
the endosymbiont that is related to
mycoplasma
during the course of our research
we actually named them name this
bacterium candidates muani plasma
glomerulomychotorum
um previously we referred to it as
mycoplasma
related endobacterium or mre
and this is
heritable bacteria
transmitted from one host generation to
the next we don't know the function of
it yet
it's found in uh
all major lineages of glomerulomycotina
so it is an important association if we
are thinking about glomerular mycotina
becoming a fertilizer substitutes in the
agriculture of the future their gene the
um
many plasma genomes are reduced about um
about one megabase when you think about
uh typical bacterial genomes e coli four
mega base many bulgaria genomes free
living and and
multi-specialized broccoli genomes eight
megabases so this is small
uh this bacterium as as suggested by the
name by the
descriptor candidatus has very limited
uh metabolic capabilities it cannot be
cultivated
it
has no uh
genetic machinery to build gram positive
walls and yet when you look at the
electron micrograph you see a wall-like
structure surrounding the cell
we don't know what this structure
is or what
where it comes from
and so we used mania fortifications
contributed by many
as a
source of the name for the genus
this bacterium has many genes and coding
proteins that are capable of interacting
with
eukaryotic proteins
it has genes horizontally acquired from
amf
and other fungi it has mobile genetic
elements
and
displays
rapid evolution and when i am saying
rapid evolution i am not joking uh
moyini plasma here on the phylogeny of
uh molecules
evolves significantly faster than
uh
microplasma galicepticum microplasma
believed to have evo to be the fastest
and evolving microbe on the planet and
our marine plasma evolves faster yet
by this phylogeny
we concluded that
moyniplasma is a product of a switch
from uh
animals to fungi but we are not
satisfied with this phylogeny this is
there is a lot of work to be done
so
um stay tuned because
once more data accumulate we might
change our mind
so what happens
well
people who study endosymbiotic bacteria
often construct these such tables to
tally
the numbers of genes or the presence
absence of genes that are involved in
genome
maintenance and stability
so
dna replica replication repair and
recombination
and here uh there are four genomes of
muani plasma
and as you can see moie plasma does not
really have
a lot of tools to repair dna
uh and this is in comparison to
antagonistic microplasmas or parasitic
microplasmas essential endosymbionts
like buchner affidicola that i mentioned
previously and tremblaya princeps that i
also mentioned previously
uh non-essential endosymbionts and
free-living bacteria
but
muay plasma has
a sizeable recombination machinery
which uh
made us to
conclude and this is an inference this
is not the truth truth uh it might
change depending on more data
um being collected
so we believe that the loss of dna rep
repair mechanisms
is really helping muani plasma to adapt
to the
host um
environment
and is also facilitating
rapid evolution
well why why many plasma genomes
are not
completely degenerate in bacterium going
extinct well we believe that the
retention of recombination machinery and
mobile genetic elements that
continuously shuffle the genomes
and uh we have
we have
uh
evidence for for these for these
statements
we believe that the retention of the
recombination and mobile genetic element
activity are contributing to
stability
stability in flux
of the of the genome
and then um
unlike the essential endosymbionts
we also believe that because ammonium
plasma is
um
an obligate endosymbiont meaning it
cannot be cultivated it relies on
metabolites from the host so its own
genes that would encode these functions
are long gone
um
in the genome
contracted but this is we believe that
this is an adaptive process
now we also believe
that this process actually happened or
has been completed
before moyni plasma
switched hosts to
fungi
and it also
not only switched hosts but it also
switched
its mode of transmission so microplasma
ancestors are
horizontally transmitted bacteria
but moini plasma is a vertically
transmitted endosymbiotic so
an example of
lifestyle and evolution patterns
that are contradictory to the paradigm
from essential endosymbios and by the
way i did not explain this figure this
is a spore of an amf fungus that is
cracked and it has released nuclei in
red and ammoniplasma
in green
and with this and there is a lot of work
to be done
and with this i am going to switch to
another endosymbiont
and this endosymbiont is uh candidates
glomerular bacterial
and actually historically
this was the very first endosymbiont of
fungi that we oh and i should say
all of this work all of this clever work
was done by a very clever
uh graduate student of my mizu naito she
was a microbiology graduate student and
beautiful
and with this uh candidates glomerular
doctor
when we
um
approach this system
there was a lot of work or a lot of
known about this particular endosymbiont
because of the work of paula bonfante
from the university of torino paola was
kind enough to let us
work on this system
and we contributed the evolutionary
framework a conceptual framework for
understanding of of this particular
endosymbiont
so it is a non-essential heritable
endosymbiont
of just one lineage of amf gigasporace
it improves uh
german elongation of the fungus
and it does it
by manipulating host
energy metabolism this is what paula
discovered and this is all we know about
this bacterium its genome is again
reduced
and remember i told you
about uh evolutionary rate
acceleration
in essential endosymbiont and i know
that you cannot really read this tree
but this is a phylogeny of
burkholderiaceae
this is
candidatus tremblaya the symbiont of
melee bugs and you can see the
ginormously elongated branch leading to
um
its sequences glomerular is here the
branch is elongated but not as long so
something different
and other endosymbions of fundraiser are
in red on this phylogeny and i will talk
about this
uh more uh glomerulobacter lives in
vesicles it's contained in vesicles
rather than
free floating in the cytoplasm like
many plasma
and so our contribution to this
particular area was
to establish
and stephen mundo who will speak next
week
did all this work
uh stephen established or inferred that
the origin of the symbiosis between
glomerubacter and amf is more than 400
million years
which means that glomerulobacter was
present in the spores of mycorrhizal
fungi when mycorrhizal fungi were
helping plants to transition to the
terrestrial
habitat and stephen was able to do this
because he reconstruct reconstructed the
phylogeny of the fungi of the
endosymbionts
um
luckily for us there were two lineages
of the hosts
and one lineage
has fossil record available to date this
phylogeny and this is the fossil record
from 400 million
years ago so based on this uh specific
pattern we were able to infer that this
is a very old symbiosis
um
is it stable well it must be stable
but how is it stable
so the back to the
to the chart that i was showing you off
to illustrate to illustrate um
mre or uh moini plasma glomerobacter is
here
glomerubacter has plenty
uh genes involved in dna
repair but it also has genes involved in
um recombination and again essential
endosymbionts that i introduced earlier
uh don't have either
so what
what what do we think about genome
evolution in glomerubacter well
glomerulobacter is uncultivable
candidates again
it acquires costly net metabolites from
the host
but
it also has a large effective population
size and we know this because steven
estimated the effective population size
and this effective population size is
related to permissive transmission
bottlenecks
many more individuals of fungal
associate fungi associated bacteria are
transmitted from host generation to host
generation than the
bacteria associated with insects and we
also have evidence of rare recombination
so both of these contribute to the large
effective populations
so what happens is
the
genome reduction
is adaptive
because only the genes
that encode for costly metabolites that
can be obtained from the fungus were
lost
and the genome contracted in an adaptive
fashion
uh
i told you that glomerubacter is on an
on a slightly an elongated branch
and we believe
that that slight molecular
rate acceleration
is uh associated with rare recombination
if you have a lot of recombination you
don't really gain branch legs but if you
have very low recombination you
switch
large chunks of the genome so every time
you reconstruct the phylogeny you
add a branch length um
according to the number of recombination
events and again i did not explain this
figure this is a figure from paula
bonfante
red are fungal nuclei
green specks are glomerulobacter cells
so
what do we think
uh we believe that the molecular
revolution path evolution patterns in
bacterial endosymbionts of fungi are
different
from the paradigm established
uh or challenged the paradigm
established for
uh essential endosymbionts of insects
and these mechanisms these patterns are
consistent with the mechanisms
that
could contribute to evolutionary
stability
of these associations and this is why we
believe that the
what for in the case of glomerular
vector this is what contributed to the
400
uh million uh
year old age of this association none of
the associations that insect form
insects form with their endobacteria is
that old
but um you guys might
and i
frankly
think about this work as a
a very fun conceptual
um
entertainment i should say although
there's fungi that we study are very
important and we really need to know
what bacteria do to them
but it's very conceptual
and satisfying for an evolutionary
biologist because
we cannot really draw satisfaction
from actual functional
characterization of this system of these
systems because
our muscular mycorrhizal function are
very difficult to cultivate and work
but
when stephen was a graduate student in
the lab we stumbled
on a completely different
um symbiotic associations and this is
the association between rhizopus
microsporus and my set of habitants my
set of habitants was previously called
burkholderia
and rhizopus microsporus is a member of
subphylum mucoromycotina it causes
rice seeded sibling blight
these are high aerial hyphae and
sporangiospores
of the fungus this is a hyphal fragment
showing
cells of bacteria and there are these
are two spores filled with bacteria
ready to for this person
so
this is this is a representative of much
mycotina
and just to remind you about
muchoromycotina
they are ubiquitous soil saprotrophs
they are food spoilage agents they are
plant pathogens responsible for
post-harvest crop disease diseases
importantly
they are opportunistic pathogens of
immunocompromised humans and rhizopus
microspores tops the list of causal
agent
agents of mukher mycosis so this is
actually fortuitously we stumbled upon
searching and living in our symbiotic
world we stumbled upon a fungus that is
actually a very significant um fungus to
human health nuclear mycotina have
multiple applications cheese making
biodiesel production and they happen to
be
one of the least
understood i am looking at nicole and
she's smirking because the pagan
michaels are even less understood but um
yukar and mike are actually important so
um
this is this is something that needs
studying
so the symbiosis between rhizopus
microsporos and mycetal habitats
it is a heritable mutualism
it is easy to manipulate experimentally
we can grow the fungus we can take
bacteria out of the fungus we can
cultivate bacteria separately we can put
bacteria back into the fungus
and now thanks to our collaborators uh
victor garrett at the university of
murcia
uh we can uh transform both both the
fungus which is the newest development
and a bacteria have been transformable
long
long ago
and the cool thing is that so this is
this harks back to the title
manipulation
uh my set of habitants
manipulates fungal reproductive biology
and stephen our stephen demonstrated
this
by making
uh isolate compatible mates with
bacteria they made gloriously showing
this orange line of beta carotene and
accumulation of zygospores but when
steven cured the fungi
they would not mate
and another pair of isolates
when they had bacteria they made it fine
but when bacteria were removed they
mated
with
much less
vigor
so we concluded this bacterium is
important and the fungus is addicted to
it because as soon as we put the
bacterium in
it resumes its reproductive activity
this um
mutualism and i did not tell you about
the mutualism per se so the mutualism is
about uh myself inhabitants producing
secular secondary metabolites that the
fungus is using to
uh in pathogen pathogenesis of rice
plants but not humans
so
this mutualism evolved from antagonism
and we know that
because the basal
isolates of my of rhizopus microsporos
uh are non-host isolates so this system
is actually beautiful glorious system to
study some biotic associations because
we have
host strains of the fungus
which we can manipulate
pick apart uh put together but there are
also in the species of rhizopus
microspores isolates that are non-hosts
they go about their life happily without
bacteria present
and what's more
the non-hosts
don't re they do not become infected
by bacteria isolated from the host
they defend themselves
so uh
another graduate student in the lab olga
lastovsky
uh conducted transcriptional
profiling
of interactions between
hosts
uh that was uh previously cured
and bacteria isolated from from it from
its hyphae
and the non-host
and bacteria isolated from the host
before the partners came to into
physical contact and after the partners
are
touched contacted
and so this is being this being a
transcriptional
um profiling study
uh the only thing that we could conclude
was a whole bunch of hypothesis
and
so these are the hypotheses that we
are constructed
in the pre-contact
bacteria do not distinguish between host
and non-host
they express the same set of genes
but the fungi actually
differ already in their responses
and those responses suggest that the
fungi are remodeling their cell walls
hosts to
welcome the bacterium
host is upregulating
chitin synthesis and the bacterium has
chitinases to
digest the wall but the non-host
upregulates uh
expression of beta gluconases
to protect as if to protect itself
now the these these responses for shadow
words happen what is happening
in the contact
um so the cell wall
um
encoding genes uh are expressed
in in a full spectrum
in addition
uh reactive oxygen species come into
play
and the non-host
produces or well well actually we know
that it produces a potent reactive
oxygen burst
in but from transcriptional profiling we
could only hypothesize this
and the no and the
non-host a potent uh reactive oxygen
burst
the host
a low peak of reactive oxygen species
and quenching
and bacterium on their part
are doing their thing pumping uh
effectors
into the host
and um upregulating stress response
um
mechanisms in response to the non-host
so the only hypothesis that we actually
tested
was the reactive oxygen hypothesis and
we were able to show that indeed as
predicted by our transcriptional
profiling the non-host when exposed to
bacteria so that this is um and not
nitro blue tetrazolium staining
and
the reagent
is
yellow and it turns purple when exposed
to
um oxygen or to free radicals so
visually and
quantify
quantitatively
uh we can see that the non-host responds
with a potent burst
um whereas the host actually uh is
producing more reactive oxygen species
when bacteria are not there
so
we started thinking about this
in
these defense responses
in the non-host inter-under antagonistic
interaction
resemble to us innate immunity responses
in animals
in
plants
and again i am not going to offend you
going out over these
these uh flow charts
because you guys all know that about
pattern recognition receptors detecting
um um
microbe associated molecular patterns
in
about extra and intracellular perception
of mumps and
effectors and then resp response modules
response modules include antimicrobial
peptides reactive oxygen species
and regulated cell death and uh it turns
out that both plants and animals have
those innate immunity systems
and they are very similar but different
because they evolved convergently so
both plants and animals zeroed on
defenses against microbes and we think
fungi did the same in a very similar way
so we became interested
in regulated cell death
the the
which is in um
plants
epitomized by hyper
hypersensitive response
and in animals in pyro by pyroptosis
so the question is
do innate immune responses of mukuru
mykotina involve regulated
cell death
and i should
you guys might think that we are doing
toy projects and kind of evolution
playing evolutionary games well this is
not a toy project this is actually
setting a baseline for a genetic screen
to
identify
genes involved in
fungal immunity
uh in particular immunity of mucoro
mycotina to devise
therapeutic strategies to treat
muchor mycosis and i did not say that
but mucoromicosis is the most difficult
to treat mycosis because mucouro
mycotina are the
are by far more resistant to any
antimicrobial agents from all fungi so
it's not trivial
but we're having fun with this
regardless so much
are capable of
apoptosis like cell death and it was
actually demonstrated
one of our model species was actually
one of the first fungi
in which apoptosis like
our cell death was demonstrated and uh
dies or commits suicide in response to
lovastatin lobostatin is a drug
anti-cholesterol drug
and uh in um
works by inhibiting prenulation of small
g proteins like grass proteins rust
proteins are
are uh key to
key master master regulators of fungal
both
vegetative and reproductive biology so
here are spores of
mukhor without lovastatin generate
germinating happily this is plus
lovastatin and you can see without
lovastatin you can see nuclei and and
spores happy with lovastatin uh cells
collapse and nuke and and dna the greats
now there are more types
of
regulated cell death than just
apoptosis
we all know and are familiar with
hypersensitive response in plants
but animals can do a whole array of
different types of regulated cell death
and what
maria laura
made this beautiful cartoon for me um
what she included are only the debts
or types of debt
that are
um
elements of
are found in fungi
so different fungi have um when they die
have homologs
of various elements of cellular
machinery that animals have and deploy
in those different types of regulated
cell death
we actually reconstructed a hypothetical
innate immunity and apoptosis like death
signaling network
in mucor because we know that muchor can
die apoptotic like death
so it has all the g well it has some of
the genes and and more
and then we
started looking for evidence of
regulated cell death
in
mucor and rhizopus
when in response to mycetal habitats and
this is glorious work by
maria laura who sits here
and so this is uh nuker
interacting with my habitat habitants
isolated from
um
rhizopus microscopes
this is this is uh uh
starting point um spores are just
starting to germinate and you can see
green bacterial specs
when moocher is left alone without its
bacterial nemesis it germinates just
fine but when bacteria are present after
four hours of interaction something
happens
and these germ tubes are not happy they
are
thickened and they are heavily
vacuolized and this is live dead
staining so like that staining is um
there are two dyes propidium iodide that
penetrates membranes only in if
membranes are compromised and cytocyto
is able to penetrate physiologically
live membranes so things that are green
are live things are that are
um
red have their membrane membranes
compromised propidium iodide can get in
and bind to their nuclei so there are
all instances of
germans already dying in the presence of
myself inhabitants and uh we
even though our project is really
focused on mukher we would wouldn't
leave um
rhizopus alone so uh this is a time
course of rhizopus microsporos non-host
you've seen this non-host
in transcriptional profiling experiment
interacting with mycetal habitants
without bacterium it germinates just
fine happily but when bacteria are
present
the germ tubes are again swollen and
vacuolized
but it's not only the fungus
who is unhappy you can see these swarms
of red or red clouds these red clouds
are bacterial cells that are dying
because fungus the known host is
defending itself and most likely pumping
reactive oxygen species
into the environment
so
our next task
is to
figure out
which
specific type of cell death
we are dealing with
our bet is on
autophagy induced death because it
involves vacuolization but we have not
done any assays any tests to confirm
them to confirm this but this is
something that we are working on
and so i am not going to torture you
any more conclusions
uh heritable endobacterial fungi display
molecular evolution patterns that are
distinctly different than uh from
essential endosymbionts of insects
and they suggest
mechanisms that stabilize those
associations
over long evolutionary periods and
if we were to single out these
mechanisms genetic recombination uh
mobile genetic element activity and i
did not really talk about host
manipulation i meant to talk about house
house manipulation but then we stumbled
up on the uh regulated cell death and i
thought it was just far more fun to to
talk about this
now all this work all the work that we
did
on end of symbionts of our vascular
mycorrhizal fungi
we did this was evolutionary
biology exercise we did not really
think about these symbiotic associations
in a functional context in a context
that these associations must have
started somehow 400 million years ago
and
there was
innate immunity
or some kind of defense involved so now
we are we are thinking back to this and
we are exploring innate immunity in
rhizobius microscopes myself inhabitants
and i did not mention this but this is
actually a very young association
and
in
the cool stuff and very recent is that
innate immunity in fungi involves
regulated
cell death
like
innate immunity mechanisms in animals
and in plants
and with this i would like to
acknowledge
people
who are in the lab
presently
all that are
former lab members
who worked on these projects
in the past
our
cornell collaborators
our collaborators
from other places our sources of funding
and i will be happy to answer questions
in the last three minutes perhaps
thank you
okay the zoom audience okay gary i
really appreciated his talk that's
really interesting uh you may have
mentioned this but i'm not sure
any evidence at this point that the
endosymbionts have any function in the
in the pathogenicity of uh
immuno-paper nice mammals
so
there is a study i'm sorry
repeat any evidence that the fungus has
impact on pathogenicity in humans so
this is rhizopus microsoft there was a
study
that uh demonstrated that
no
but we are wondering about this so that
that it's not an a close case
thank you thanks
any other questions
you know if you um
you said if you cured the fungus of the
bacteria that it couldn't eat anymore do
you know
if that's a nutrient thing and if you
give it nutrients in the media can you
fix that or
do you know why do you know like what's
causing what the lack is so laurie's
question was what is the cause of loss
of sex when bacteria are cured from from
rhizopus microsporus so steven actually
did transcriptional profiling in a
bacterial effect expression of one of
the rust genes
that is important for regulation of i
mean we don't know what there is
because um rhizopus has so many copies
of races that it's difficult to figure
out what which is doing but we suspect
that this particular one is important
for
um uh for um sexual reproduction and we
are actually pursuing this further we
actually want to um understand the
mechanism uh by which the fun the
bacterium controls the fungus and we
suspect that this is an epigenetic
mechanism and this is in the work
actively in the works
thank you
any other questions
nicole
i was just wondering how you think
sexual reproduction of the fungal host
affects the population genetics of the
endosymbios
um
yes we don't know because we were not
able to germinate zygo's force and um
again
we it was not for lack of trying
zygospores of
um i couldn't are very challenging to
germinate so we have bacteria labeled
with
fluorescent markers and we would really
like to see how they mix and match
but it's um in in we
actually um
are um doing well we have preliminary
data on population structure of
endosymbionts and the hosts
but it's it's just not informative
really really
at this point
um i understand you're showing conflict
between the non-hosts
and studying immunity from that are
there examples of when the host
and indissimulate mutualism shift
to a conflict maybe when there's
resources limited or
different stages
yeah so you know
all mutualistic interactions are
a continuum in there
like even our vascular mycorrhizae you
can drive the partners to a situation
when the fungus is actually parasitizing
the
the plant so it's it's possible but i
think what we have here is
we have
uh
genetic
um
determination of hostness versus
non-hostness
or
being
a competent versus
non-competent host
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu